Oh Jay Simpson could be just hours away
from being released on parole after an
armed robbery conviction but his
acquittal in a dramatic 1995 murder
trial still provokes very strong
feelings among many Americans a recent
CBS News poll shows that 71 percent
believe that OJ Simpson is guilty of the
murders of his former wife Nicole Brown
Simpson and her friend Ron Goldman but
there is still a racial divide in how
people see this case about eight and ten
white Americans think he's guilty just
four and ten black Americans believe his
opinion among black Americans has
shifted though twice as many now think
that OJ Simpson is guilty than they did
back in 1995 just after his trial in a
preview of a 48 hours special tomorrow
CBS News special correspondent that's
James Brown explores a heated dialogue
among the ongoing racial divide in this
country I think OJ got away with so much
that he really actually thought he was a
god I basically has spent a
conflict-free life Oh Jay Simpson has
stood in the center of this country's
fascination with race celebrity and
justice ever since being accused of the
1994 brutal murder of his ex-wife Nicole
Brown Simpson and friend Ron Goldman Oh
Jay could not have committed these
murders how often do you get to see you
know an American icon like this on trial
for murder there was violence through
the thread of their marriage I think
it's important to represent my sister we
need to look at these relationships not
as abusive relationships but as
potential murder cases I would not have
the blood of Nicole on ron shipp ron
shipp was a close family friend former
LAPD who had trained officers in
domestic violence had tried to counsel
both of them he testified for the
prosecution many in the black community
considered you to be a traitor it hit me
really bad
he divided us if it doesn't fit you
must acquit he defined us you have not
addressed any black person as a or
spoken about black people as that's what
I'm saying sir la was still reeling from
the horrific images of Rodney King a
black man beaten by white police
officers who had been acquitted or
installed James Simpson not guilty of
the crime of murder people were cheering
OJ Simpson per say they were cheering
that what it seemed that the criminal
justice system balanced in favor of a
black person and still we Americans
can't get past that he got away with
murder
Oh Jay Simpson man could not get back on
track and then there was Vegas
[Music]
convicted of robbery and kidnapping
while trying to get back his own
memorabilia while Simpson was kept off
the streets America witnessed tensions
between police and the black community
become painfully raw and now that racial
tension is at the heart of the exploding
NFL players protest a seventy-year-old
OJ Simpson is about to walk out of
prison given parole after nine years
thank you not guilty of the raging
dialogue he ignited resonates louder
than ever why is there still a
fascination associated with OJ in 2017
because it reflects where we still are
today on matters of race boy James Brown
joins us at the table to discuss I
remember so vividly when that verdict
was first released but help us
understand the timeline here about when
he could actually get out of prison
technically he's available to walk at
12:01 a.m. Sunday morning but word on
the street is that it will probably be
Monday because the prison authorities
may not want to pay all the overtime for
the staff that has to be there for the
media circus that certainly will occur
when he does walk out of prison
said what he's gonna do when he gets out
of prison no one knows definitively but
he has articulated strongly that he
wants to spend time with his kids he's
probably gonna head back to Florida look
the terms of the parole are are woven
with a number of speed bumps and
thickets that we will that he's gonna
have to navigate in order to not violate
parole because any violation of any of
those and he's back in remember that
sentence was from 9 years to 33 years in
prison any expectation he'll speak out
about about his trial about his life
about anyone doing anything right now
yeah you know what Charlie
you never know with OJ I mean his
friends say that it's hard for him to
stay out of the spotlight that he
probably will and certainly we know
what's going on in the country today
with race still being the third rail of
any conversation in any kind of group
and certainly what's happening in the
NFL today my personal opinion I don't
think that his voice would help matters
at all great piece of reporting yeah I
can't wait to soak right now looking
forward to it okay may I say we can tell
your weight loss congratulations
thank you without the Spanx now right
okay thank you very much great thank you
James Brown you can see his full 48
hours special OJ Simpson end game
Saturday night at 9:00 8:00 central
right here on CBS now it's part of a 48
hours double feature and today on the
CBS s morning podcast 48 hours
correspondent Erin Moriarty talks about
her experience covering the OJ Simpson
trial Plus how 48 hours has evolved over
the last 30 years you can listen to our
podcast on iTunes and Apple's podcast
app